[Music]
john
is with us in uh pennsylvania hi john
how are you
i'm doing well dave thanks for taking my
call i appreciate it sure what's up
um so i think i'm in baby step three but
i'm not
sure um i paid paid off all our debt and
paid off
recently finished paying off the car
we're debt-free except uh
my oldest son um i've co-signed some of
his college loans
so i'm not sure uh
should i put them into my debt snowball
and start paying them off or
just you know step in if if he starts
having trouble paying
him is he paying them uh well he just
graduated in may
and he's still looking for a job okay so
he's got six months for he has to start
paying
yeah what's that how much is owed on
these loans
uh well all together it's right about 30
000.
how much debt have you paid off so far
um well really haven't paid off anything
there there's
a couple different loans oh i thought
you were on and you say you paid off
some debt
my debt yes i'm sorry um
uh gosh uh probably close to
ninety six thousand wow ninety
yeah nine six thousand what do you make
household income uh
household income is about 79. okay
well you've done very very well yeah
well i mean
this is what this is what accountants
call a contingent
liability meaning that you are liable
if he doesn't pay that's what co-signing
sets you up for
so uh you you are technically debt-free
you're technically on baby step three
okay uh i would want your baby step
three to be pretty beefy
your emergency fund so don't do three to
six go
like six to eight or so yeah yeah i'm
gonna probably
cheat a little bit up in the eight side
just to kind of offset the fact that you
have a kid that has not gotten a job
and he's got thirty thousand dollars
he's supposed to start paying on and if
he doesn't you're about to
and if you have if you have to start
paying the payments because he doesn't
then i'm just going to treat it like my
debt i'm going to stop everything and
knock it out
yeah he's got a computer science degree
and he did very well in school so we're
pretty confident he's going to get a
decent paying job
me too but i'm just you know at the
moment
uh for today i would just set aside
extra
but at the six-month mark if he doesn't
start paying this on time and they start
bothering you
just roll up your sleeves and knock it
out okay and john take him
if you haven't already take him to lunch
because he is going to get a good job
and make sure he knows to not go buy a
car in a fancy apartment put him into
financial peace university knock this
thing off yeah
well so we found out about you about two
years ago um
but before you know uh he went off to
the college he went to
um and and so it's a little bit of a
moral issue for me because my my
youngest son
um he's sort of getting a free ride uh
because i work at a college yeah and
so he we're getting like a tremendous
discount uh
for him um why didn't the other one go
there they didn't have the degree he
wanted
at my school yeah so okay well i mean i
i don't know
i don't see it as a moral issue listen
fair is something that happens at the
county
yeah that's a great line dave
good one you know so i mean it's just it
is what it is
if you've got a child that has uh that
is in a you know a different situation
then
it's a different situation and so equal
is not fair fair is not equal
and that's that's uh that's just part of
the way life works out and uh
i i you know my kids did not get the
exact
same amount uh the younger one ended up
with
possibly more because we had a better
start by the time he came along
and uh but they've it's all worked out
for all of them they're gonna be just
fine
so and you can do something that blesses
one of the other ones a little bit later
if you want to or something like that
the one that you didn't cost you
anything you know that kind of thing but
anyway yeah you can help if you want to
help but i would be prepared to pay it
off immediately as fast as you can
if he fails in paying it that's the way
i would position it
thank you